thank you dig each refers to a to verse
salads a freshman at the first sight to
first I can't remember but I believe you
were the first one to get the first head
to earth
[Music]
my favorite tattoo is my tattoo on my
bed it's a peacock I got it
approximately four months ago is she
crazy took about six hours
anyhow you're like a [ __ ] but it
was worth it tattoos was feeling great
all of them I love gin tattoos I think
it's just a myth that some hurt more
than others nerd
he was one of my favorite characters
Nickelodeon ever made he was like a
robot dog he was supposed to be helping
this guy in babies in take over the
earth please like real cool and funny
very low yeah he's kind of slow but he
was also tight though he had all the
swag I love he ain't say today sometimes
yeah man I got this one recently I got
this one like this year at the cotton
cloud right here it's a secret
organization so everybody who sees this
and that knows what the kotsky is
they'll hit y'all look you know I'm
saying
shrim like if I got the shrimp on my
chest right here open my heart I got
some on my back that's what we live by
that's what pays our bills with support
says that's how we exist I got this
[ __ ] protector right here just
protect me from our domain [ __ ]
[Music]
like when I try want to get tattoos in
different cities so this my own middle
name it says even it means Sun up and if
you know me you know your if you don't
you just don't know me you don't know
him and then like I got the yin and yang
to symbolize balance yeah I mean Jim is
yang you know I'm saying rebalance over
here I got like a lot of sacred geometry
to is like really cementery and just
crazy and it means like its it also
represents bradley's to me and I'm like
this sacred Gentry does right and here
on my chest I got the torches like you
know when the King come through like all
the Knights they had two torches lit
like make way this with this muffin
coming through like they're not my
stomach I got this lantern if you know
anything about Lynch's like they used to
light up the dark so that's what I did
is I got this RAM on my chest it mean
I'm just want a head first and Bubba
shut up
come to light if there's something
blocking me and we get to it then I got
the galaxy on my neck because music my
vocal cords they opened up a different
world for me it took me to another
universe so I got the galaxy on my neck
right there when I have an idea for a
tattoo I wait until the next opportunity
I have and I eat it man I got this when
I was 14 minutes honestly it's the I had
the tiger
I just went hard the first time that
basically yeah in a hotel room they do
is like drinking is my head
we thought it was late then he was like
doing our test fit we're getting helmet
at for real Qi he got some crazy weather
his wolf crazy too but he had his right
ear over the rowdy rough boy
I'm with nineties baby man we used to
watch the Powerpuff Girls it was tight
the Pharaoh you know there's a king I
feel like I'm a king so I got there and
then I you know I got the power sign
right under day it's like the universal
sign papel turn it on turn it off you
know and then I got just a bad female
right here you know saying what is a
Geisha though he's occasion to Japanese
geisha without you know just beauty you
know it sounds like duty then this is c6
- this is my area code oh yeah
this one for Miss Mississippi - a
success - stay with me so we all are
Mississippi homies well we came from the
city we blew it from like we went in
just got like we drew it everybody wrote
it out my advice if you want to get
tattoos just ask your mom before you get
face tattoos because that's the face
that she gave you might get my son named
Teddy yeah I'm gonna get it on my face
across like this